every now and then Wolfen frets lifts a
sense of a one-of-a-kind antique and
chase it to a place that's dark strange
or even dangerous here are some times
that American Pickers found weirdness
along with the treasures when Captain
Kirk from Star Trek makes an order you
take it hit contact did the antique
archeology and spoke with Danielle Colby
who passed along the message to Mike
Wolfe and Frank Fritz that William
Shatner wanted nay needed an antique
Milla stone for his garden sure enough
[ __ ] are the best in the business the
Pickers found a Millie stone but I can
take tool used to process grain hardly a
jaded Hollywood bigshots
Shatner made the surreal moments even
more delicious with some breathless
declarations this is the signature piece
DM mill stone is genius in a second
season episode the Pickers went deep
into Kentucky to the home of an older
couple named dawn and the net they had a
bomb with that tossed all kinds of junk
from branded signs old TV sets
that's wolf looked around he noticed a
curtain that would otherwise have
blended into the wall apparently not
worried about the deadly spiders or
ghosts he boldly just stuck his head
through the opening and came out wearing
a very old oversized grotesque mask of
screen comedian Stan Laurel the word is
Laurel there's longtime comedy partner
Oliver Hardy
sure enough there was another even
creepier mask that fritz put on his head
the masks were crumbling and probably
haunted but the pair bought them anyway
the Pickers have made multiple visits to
the home of Ron aka The Mole Man but
it's a typical looking American Pickers
rural property with several outbuildings
filled with intriguing prospects as
Ron's actual home it's more than 20 feet
beneath in fact in the 2013 episode wolf
and Fritz arrived to Ron's home and
announced and attempted navigate the
seemingly endless cavernous maze like
tunnels that Ron's been developing since
1965 the guys squeezed through narrow
tunnels walking on narrow planks pass
would send the blocks and junk until
they get to a dead end and have to try
another route places like Indiana Jones
meets Sanford and Son the narrow paths
you know all that stuff I mean I'm
jiving on this
toward the end then wisely hurry through
creeped out as they are until they reach
Ron's door found beyond the single piece
of word place over a 20 foot deep pit on
a picking swing through New England in
2018 whooping Fritz visited a lush Lee
wooded property in Chesterfield
Massachusetts the
set them to remote corner of his land
and showed them a thoroughly rusted
vehicle decorated with a long-nosed
cartoon character in a striped shirt and
the word Aerosmith
could this derelict van actually up
belong to the band Aerosmith they were
local to Boston wolf managed to make
contact with an early member of
Aerosmith who confirmed that yes this
was the band's touring van upon looking
through the van the pig has found
Persian rugs old Budweiser cans a three
dog night sticker and two of the
filthiest mattresses that ever existed
home of taters an American original a
pioneer in the uniquely American art
form of the roadside attraction he
specialized in making hideous macabre
artifacts out of paper mache mud and
real animal bones then he advertised
them as real fines not artistic
creations in the 1940s and 50s getting
people to stop and take a gander for a
small fee Tate is probably best known
for the thing an Arizona roadside oddity
purporting to be a mummified mother and
child he eventually opened Tate's
curiosity shop to display his wares and
it's full of the kind of stuff the
American Pickers love to find indeed
wolfin Fritz came face-to-face with wolf
boy a Homer Tate original that looks
like a combination of ET and a turtle if
either creature had fangs the story is
that it's one of 26 mummies discovered
in a cave in Peru but it's merely an
eerie fake no matter what a viewers
opinion on taxidermy may be that have to
admit that a giant building in rural New
England in which every square inch is
occupied by a dead stuffed animal is
pretty weird often Fritz visited the
very place in a 2012 American Vickers
episode and grew transfixed with two
well-preserved
elephant heads one partially real the
other entirely artificial wolf decided
he simply had to have the mostly real
one and paid an outstanding $9,500 for
it with so much capital tied up in the
elephant head the pig is needed to
unload it quickly as possible and for as
much money as possible they test
Danielle back at the shop with finding a
buyer I sent the boys to pick taxidermy
stuff I thought maybe they'd come back
with a deer head some antlers squirrel
no they come back vanilla fin head who
buys an elephant head astonishingly she
located one in buck star Jack White's a
guy who loves pachyderm so much he named
the white striped classic 2003 album
elephants white tried to talk down the
price but the Pickers having sons such a
huge sum of cash into their find didn't
lots of wiggle room eventually why
proposed the deal you'd get the elephant
head at their price if he threw in some
American Pickers worthy bits of
old-school Americana specifically a
black-and-white photo booth and a
jukebox the Pickers took the deal then
had to shell out an extra $1,000 to ship
the elephant head Rockford Illinois is
famously the home of the great American
rock band cheap trick and Fritz a big
fan was extremely excited to see Rick's
picks a rock and roll museum curated by
and featuring the assorted musical
memorabilia of cheap trick guitarist
Rick Nielsen known for his boisterous
stage personality
Nielsen's huge collection wild fritzen
wolf it included a number of the
musicians famous novelty guitars
including a Czech patterned instruments
and one with five necks Nielson invited
the Pickers to his warehouse to see even
more of his stuff and the guys dropped
about $2,500 on some albums a poster
t-shirts and traveling cases but they've
really wanted to take home one of
Nielsen's guitars they haggled for a
while but Nielsen just wouldn't
surrender his piece he finally left
Fritz and Wolfe have it for free on the
condition that they keep it on display
at antique archaeology they can't sell
it in Nashville so I can play it on
Saturday or Sunday or whenever you want
you guys take it down there are you
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
you